last year Apple went big with the iPhone
6 this year it's bulking up the iPad
with a jumbo sized tablet called the
ipad pro the pro is a big shift in
direction for apple's ipad line it's big
with a 12 point 9 inch screen versus the
9.7 inch ipad air it also has a
separately sold Apple pencil a stylus
and accessories of Steve Jobs once
ridiculed as unnecessary and perhaps the
tablets neatest feature you can open one
app and then split the screen accessing
all your other apps the tablet is
running an a 9x shift which apple says
it's faster than eighty percent of the
portable PCs have shipped in the last
year there are four speakers which
automatically recalibrate the sound
depending on how you hold the tablet
it's also six point nine millimeters
thin a little thicker than the ipad air
6.1 millimeters Apple is also taking a
page from the Microsoft Surface with a
keyboard accessory it connects to three
magnetic circles on the ipad pro called
a smart connector which transmits data
and power the ipad pro is aimed
primarily at corporate customers and run
specially tailored versions of microsoft
office and adobe photoshop it starts at
seven ninety-nine with an additional
ninety nine dollars for the pencil and
169 for the smart keyboard it goes on
sale in november and Apple is hoping the
pro to give a boost to a tablet sales
you